and I'm and I'm thick now I'm thick if
you see my the last Instagram post I
posted against Chris Oh at the white you
see what you see how menacing I look
with two knives I think I feel like
Chris is put on some weight right yeah
honestly everybody its Yun steroid he's
he's Juicin boy he's scared of liquor
little loan steroids yeah he's got how
thick no but I want a membership to his
garage man yeah you know that's
incredible look it up oh yeah look at
him there it is I think Swartz in had a
really good neck isn't my drama and I'm
all trapped you know what you look like
then that pic you look up to a cholo in
that picture you look like a la you're
very strange
yeah B you can see I'm ready and Chris
is literally dressed like me when he
used to make fun of the way I dress all
this also looks like you didn't want to
take that picture yeah it's like you 101
that's that's a samurai sword from the
1500s I Got News for him you should
always say it's not you say that's a lie
it's not because he was told that but
it's it's it's not in fact it was made
probably 5 years ago in some factory but
well I'm gonna let him go even though
that because because look this up chin
samurai swords from the 1500s anybody
who'd practice Bushido and and and was a
true samurai oshi is the these the metal
was folded it's full that's not folded
metal [ __ ] now that's some [ __ ]
stainless steel first two hundred
thousand how do you how can you tell the
difference
no scroll up he is right there I
practice yuge I practiced in Kenshin
Japanese samurai swords three grand in
dough three grand son no that's not a
real candle in a sword fighting 15th
century really sounds like a a gambling
yeah why would it be 200 grand
I don't know I figured that their Museum
made all this up huh let me show you
hundred grand I should get some songs
sound the metal is folded no I don't
know what you're talking about
what is that I believe Rogan I don't
know Brennan because from from 500 years
old
are you guys telling me that it would
look like that yeah I don't think
they're metal yeah metal metal wasn't it
was I don't know
here listen was it stainless steel i
will never draw my sword unless i'm
gonna i'm gonna draw blood
well come on for folding basically makes
the steel more uniform throughout the
blades length modern smell think anna
cheese up the more quality still using
agent smelting huh always and you know
that [ __ ] that can you have more
samurai swords and will buy one for the
[ __ ] air brian's we know that just by
looking at it yeah i know by touching me
touch so so I know now listen when you
understand blades when you win a blade
is real and it can cut you touch it you
go there you go 220 commentary that's
what I mean and I listen yeah when you
touch it it's like this it's so cold
that it burns
like that and that's what I'm saying
see what I'm saying that's a 223 that's
a museum relic to get the real deal is
museums I look 6 grand 4 grand I don't
know is I don't think those what are
y'all you got a million-dollar sword Oh
somebody plans right you know someone
museum piece million dollars it's a real
samurai sword why are you saying it like
that sorry cuz I speak you're showing
right now you see that blade you see
what I mean yeah he'll know that was an
ancient that was an ancient smelting
technique
mm-hmm and you and your maken we smell I
just point something out though about
all this like they were making swords
back then when they didn't have the
technology to make them like better like
they can now so why is that more than
like now it's a relic and it's from then
and it's it is sad have you remember
those those swords I won't get in the
right lane with you remember the five
raised by Mew multiple Sachi well I
apologize and a great deal about they're
not [ __ ] Japanese I'm just sayin you
just lumped in Vietnamese and Koreans
with Japanese the most I think more
insulting to both a little trance of
what you're doing I'm speaking Japanese
I'm not pronouncing it your multiple
seshu is the way you say his name is you
say I was gonna ask you guys if he's
saying it right but then that's but you
said it cut out there I studied cut out
they for many many years you here to
school that's a martial arts right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]